usa 4 stunden von chicago herzen des
mittleren westens liegt die stadt einem
aussah
dreh und angelpunkt ist das
hochsicherheitsgefängnis
hinter diesen mauern sitzen
schwerverbrecher und viele werden diesen
ort nicht mehr verlassen
[Musik]
die wichtel stimmen an frischer luft
viel trainieren gangmitglieder
drogenbosse
sexualstraftäter und mörder
zu bauen stress ab
hilft mir dinge zu vergessen und einen
klaren kopf zu behalten
die einrichtung beherbergt über 1000
häftlinge das zusammenleben ist oft
nicht einfach
heute kam es zu einer auseinandersetzung
zwischen mehreren gefangenen
was zum teufel ist los
200 meter weiter gibt es eine schlägerei
das personal ist immer in
alarmbereitschaft
das sind 20 typen
insgesamt 20 mitglieder von zwei gangs
prügeln aufeinander ein die wörter
müssen verhindern dass es zu weiteren
ausschreitungen kommt innerhalb weniger
minuten bringen sie die situation unter
kontrolle
keiner ist verletzt doch der einsatz von
tränengas hat seine spuren hinterlassen
ich sterbe nein du hast du nicht fühlt
sich vielleicht so an aber du stirbst
nicht
das tränengas macht ihm zu schaffen er
hat angst
office evans und sein team regeln die
gesamte einrichtung ab
die insassen müssen zurück in ihre
zellen
wahrscheinlich wings mit einem streit
zwischen zwei typen aus
unterschiedlichen gangs an aber wir
wissen es nicht genau
auch in andern
die gefangenen die an der schlägerei
beteiligt waren erwartet eine harte
strafe
einzelhaft
schlimmer geht es nicht
eine lehre zelle ohne persönliche
gegenstände
das soll sie zum reden bringen doch im
gefängnis redet niemand
[Musik]
es ist ein ungeschriebenes gesetz so
hält die klappe versteht ihr
ich bin kein verräter ich weiß nicht
warum
sein stolz seine würde alles wird durch
den dreck gezogen verstehst du verlierst
dein gesicht die wörter werden kaum an
geständnisse kommen dicht halten zu
können ist im gefängnis
überlebenswichtige
aus einer moser gibt es kein entkommen
die insassen nennen es den weißen palast
des westens seine gotische architektur
erinnert eher an ein spukschloss als an
einer haftanstalt
das gefängnis wurde 1880 gebaut und ist
eines der ältesten in den vereinigten
staaten in den letzten 60 jahren gab es
keinen erfolgreichen ausbruchsversuch
die häftlinge stehen unter ständiger
überwachung
dafür sind die fast 200 wörtern
zuständigen
wir müssen immer aufs schlimmste
vorbereitet sein
deshalb werden auch alle telefonate
abgehört
in einer moschee stehen besonders die
gangs im fokus kriminelle organisationen
die unter anderem mit drogen dealen
das tattoo hier kripp zu denen gehöre
ich
das ist eine erinnerung an meinen bruder
die polizei hat 17 mal auf ihn
geschossen die gefangenen dürfen sich
nichts erlauben
harris werk vom zaun
das kleinste vergehen und sie werden in
winzige zellen gesteckt
das leben in einem amerikanischen gulag
das ist amerika die sind krank schließen
uns weg wie tiere
1965 wurde in europa die todesstrafe
abgeschafft und durch lebenslange
haftstrafen ersetzt das betrifft in
einer maus a 20 prozent der insassen sie
werden diesen ort nie mehr verlassen
manche von ihnen bekommen regelmäßig
besuch von ihrer familie wie sie
wenn man nach langer zeit seine familie
endlich wieder sieht verdrängt man was
hier drin so abgeht
eine andere art dem alltag zu entfliehen
ist arbeit in einem us-gefängnis eigene
fabrik stellen die häftlinge
nummernschilder her
ich mache dollar 40 pro stunde
unterbezahlt und überarbeitet aber ich
mache das beste aus nach situation
mario wurde wegen raubüberfalls
verurteilt er ist ein vorzeige häftling
und genießt deswegen eine luxus zelle
luxus heißt hier drei quadratmeter
wand zu wand und decke nicht gerade groß
ich mich um sich irgendwo gegen
einen monat lang begleiten wir das leben
der häftlinge in diesem
hochsicherheitsgefängnis
in dieser festung läuft alles streng
nach protokoll
[Musik]
die heimat
wie geht's
[Musik]
was ist das das ist der schlüssel fürs
treppenhaus im wachturm
officer jones arbeitet im strategisch
wichtigsten wachturm des gefängnisses er
steht genau in der mitte der anlage und
überblickt den hof
dort kann die kleinste beleidigung zur
eskalation führen wie bei der schlägerei
die vorhin stattfand
auch darauf ist oder wie geht's nicht
viel los heute alles ruhig im hof
als erstes überprüft jones seine waffe
das ist mein gewehr ich gehe nur sicher
dass da
keine patronen drinstecken
die wärter in den wachtürmen sind als
einzige bewaffnet
immer aufs schlimmste vorbereitet sein
zum beispiel einen aufstand bei dem
wetter oder gefangenen verletzt werden
dann müssten wir einschreiten
außerdem soll es natürlich auch zur
abschreckung dienen
in den acht jahren die er hier arbeitet
musste jones seine waffe noch nie
benutzen er hat eine wichtige aufgabe er
beobachtet das verhalten der insassen
vor allem dass der gangs sobald sich
diese versammeln schreiten die werte ein
es dürfe nie mehr als sechs gefangene
zusammenstehen
die kollegen im hof
könnt ihr bitte die große gruppe
auflösen
jones sieht dass sich neun häftlinge
versammelt haben das sind zu viele
es sollten nicht mehr als sechs sein
sonst gibt es probleme
wir werden sie trennen und aufhören zu
gehen
wenn sie den wärter kommen sehen setzen
sich einige von ihnen schon in bewegung
wir beobachten sie aber sie beobachten
uns auch sie haben eine menge zeit sie
versuchen immer und seinen schritt
voraus zu sein und das versuchen wir
auch
an diesem morgen ist im hoch mehr los
als sonst damit ihre langen haftstrafen
erträglicher werden organisiert die
gefängnisleitung spezielle
veranstaltungen die heutige zeit
besonders viele zuschauer und teilnehmer
an der jährliche wettbewerb im
gewichtheben
silo ist einer der favoriten er ist
anführer einer gang der platz der
drogenboss hat einen kunden ermordet den
er für einen informanten der polizei
hielt das urteil lebenslang seit einem
jahr trainiert er um sich heute den
titel stärkster mann im knast zu
erkämpfen
ich bin bereit mental
hier oben muss man stark sein man darf
sich durch nichts aus der ruhe bringen
lassen und muss es einfach machen ich
bin bereit
doch er hat einen starken konkurrenten
toni sprüht vor energie und kommt mit
seinem leibwächter
[Musik]
hier bleib bei mir okay
toni hat den titel schon seit drei
jahren
heute ist es soweit die zeit ist reif
er sitzt wegen der entführung einer
minderjährigen
sechs tage lang war er mit einem jungen
mädchen auf der flucht er floh durch die
vereinigten staaten versteckte sein
opfer und vergewaltigte es auch sein
urteil lebenslang
gewichtheber lasst uns würdig kämpfen
gentleman
beste möge gewinnen nur die leistung
zählt ihr müsst ihr nicht tun
es kann losgehen die wachen schenkten
dem wettbewerb besondere aufmerksamkeit
jeder will miterleben wie toni gegen
seinen herausforderer ceo antritt
[Musik]
das duell beginnt bei
275 kilogramm für silo kein problem
[Musik]
alle sind beeindruckt
toni konnte mit gewichten die er extra
für den heutigen anlass rot gefärbt hat
sein leibwächter packt alles auf die
stange toni will es wissen und startet
mit einem gewicht das nie zuvor in
diesem wettbewerb gehoben wurde das
könnte auch nach hinten losgehen
340 kilogramm
das sind 65 kilo mehr als beispiele
[Musik]
[Applaus]
er sieht seine chancen schwinden
toni hat ordentlich vorgelegt
das ist eine menge
das schaffen sie mir
gerade nicht könnte aber nah ran kommen
toni genießt seinen erfolg er hat im
gefängnis eigenen rekord eingestellt
ich schwitze zu sehr ja ist gut gelaufen
ich eine menge energie gekostet deshalb
habe ich nur den einen versuch gemacht
das ist so viel gewicht dass man es kaum
wiederholen kann ich bin jetzt echt
fertig keine angst dass sie noch jemand
schlägt
das passiert nicht du bist fast 50 ja
krass oder
toni hält sich für unbesiegbar doch noch
gibt sich nicht geschlagen um nicht aus
dem wettbewerb zu fliegen versucht er
sich an
295 kilo da sind immer noch 45 weniger
als bei toni
[Musik]
er schafft es nicht ist der traum vom
sieg geplatzt
er sieht aus als hätte toni den titel
schon in der tasche doch noch ist der
wettbewerb nicht vorbei
die häftlinge dürfen nur an den
täglichen aktivitäten teilnehmen wenn
sie sich nichts zuschulden kommen lassen
verletzen sie die regeln erwarten sie
ernsthafte konsequenzen
gebäude die dritte stock und der
meistgehasste ort der einrichtung
die einzelhaft das gefängnis innerhalb
des gefängnisses
in den zellen gibt es nur das nötigste
eine toilette und ein bett
persönliche gegenstände sind nicht
erlaubt
wir verbringen die insassen täglich 23
stunden
[Musik]
die wärter begleiten sie zu ihrer
einzigen stunde freigang am tag doch
selbst draußen werden sie in käfige
gesperrt
vier quadratmeter auf denen sie sich die
beine vertreten können
richardson letzte warnung
noch mal und sie kommen rein
officers arbeitet bereits seit acht
jahren als wärter in einem moser
er las den häftlingen nichts durchgehen
sie müssen die ganze zeit gehen
sie dürfen nicht laufen liegestütze oder
sit ups machen sie dürfen nur in dem
käfig auf und ab gehen
sie dürfen die anderen insassen nicht
anschreien
wenn sie sich nicht an die regeln halten
kommen sie wieder rein und dürfen auch
morgen nicht nach draußen
das leben in einem amerikanischen gulag
das ist amerika wir sind krank schließen
uns weg wie tiere
in der zelle kriegt man platzangst
versteht ihr
traummann atmen zu können ist das das
beste am tag
das beste ist wenn ich einschlafe
dann kann ich von allem träumen was ich
hier drin nicht machen kann
er ist weg vom zaun weg
das darf keine schwäche zeigen selbst in
käfige gesperrt sind viele der insassen
gefährlich
sie dürfen sich nicht am zaun festhalten
wie er es gemacht hat sie könnten die
maschen auseinander ziehen und dann
draht abdrehen und waffen daraus machen
deswegen wollen wir nicht dass sie den
zaun anfassen der office und seine
kollegen reagieren auf die kleinste
zuwiderhandlung mit teils drastischen
methoden
ich hab ne spuk maske auf
die muss man tragen wenn man damit droht
die wörter anzuspucken oder es wirklich
macht
und das ist noch vergleichsweise harmlos
wenn wert hat mich respektlos behandelt
also habe ich ihn abgestochen
deshalb haben sie mich hierher verlegt
im gefängnis steht nur deinen ruf
wenn du nicht zu deinem wort stehst dann
lebst du gefährlich
investor schnell zum opfer
zum glück hat der wärter den angriff
überlebt
macht ihnen so was angst angst das
bringt mich zum nachdenken
wie schnell was passieren kann
mir ist noch nichts passiert was
natürlich nicht heißt
deswegen muss man auf jede kleinigkeit
achten was da los ist wie es den typen
geht wie sie reden ihre haltung was sie
mit ihren händen machen
wir haben immer alles im blick
der kurze freigang ist beendet es geht
zurück in den trakt
[Musik]
den häftlingen sind nur drei durchgänge
pro woche gestartet auch die waschräume
gleich in einer zelle
officers und nimmt den gefangenen die
handschellen erst ab wenn sie drin sind
[Musik]
er ist der einzige der zugang zu seife
und shampoo hat
ich habe noch was in meiner zelle aber
das will ich noch nicht benutzen
davon gibt es zwei wollen sie einst ja
dass nämlich mit das kann in die kiste
die insassen dürfen auch nicht ihre
eigene kleidung tragen
chávez hat auch darüber die kontrolle
unterhose gesichts handtuch
tschüss socken
das wollen wir zusammen
das ist alles was sie brauchen
wir geben ihnen kleidung die wir auf
waschen so wissen wir dass nichts drin
versteckt ist in ihre eigene kleidung
könnten sie was einnehmen deswegen
nehmen wir sie hinweg
bei dem wettbewerb im gewichtheben hat
sich das blatt gewendet toni der mit 340
kilo führt muss in einzelhaft
mithäftlinge behaupten er hat betrogen
der wörter hat diese beiden roten
gewichte konfisziert es stellte sich
heraus dass sie nicht aus metall sondern
aus holz sind
toni hat die perfekten kopien im
werkraum hergestellt ohne dass
irgendjemand verdacht geschöpft hätte
das ist eine der handel scheiben die wir
sichergestellt haben
der steht 45 kilo auf die man sehen kann
ist sie aber sehr leicht
der betrug war geschickt eingefädelt
um keinen verdacht zu erregen haben toni
und sein leibwächter die hantel scheiben
aus holz zwischen zwei aus metall
gepackt
er war der einzige der sie benutzte
niemand anderes hatte zugriff darauf
[Musik]
in einem hochsicherheitsgefängnis darf
solch ein verhalten nicht toleriert
werden auch weil es zu spannungen
zwischen den gangs führen könnte
er könnte es auch auf jemanden mit einer
anderen hautfarbe abwälzen manchmal
braucht es nicht viel mehr drin ein
konflikt zu provozieren
sowas hätte auf jeden fall das potenzial
dazu
deswegen müssen wir es ernst nehmen
wenn es eigentlich ganz lustig ist
was kleines hat ja oft große
konsequenzen
officer kraft liegt mit seiner
einschätzung goldrichtig
tony lloyd wird nicht nur die falschen
gewichte hergestellt zu haben er
behauptet auch noch er sei reingelegt
worden
jemand will mir was anhängen was denken
sie auf jeden fall um mich loszuwerden
da hat so einiges nicht gestimmt
es gab nicht mal schiedsrichter mit
anderer hautfarbe nur schwarze
silos freunde
die anderen weißen die das machen
sollten wurden nicht zugelassen
wahrscheinlich weil ich der
titelverteidiger bin und sie die nicht
dabei haben wollten die wollten mich
einfach loswerden obwohl das gar keinen
sinn macht
weiß nicht ich finde es traurig
eine ziemlich dreiste behauptung wo doch
ganz offensichtlich der betrug auf sein
konto geht seine komplizen kommen
ungeschoren davon
doch toni blühen 15 tage einzelhaft
und was für ihn noch schlimmer sein
dürfte ihr habt seinen guten ruf
verloren und ist zur lachnummer geworden
[Gelächter]
silo dagegen ist zufrieden er ist der
neue stärkste mann von einem user
[Musik]
du bist kein betrüger
alle sind beeindruckt
hat ihn noch nie geschlagen
jetzt weiß jeder wer der stärkste ist
wir sehen uns gut gemacht
ich bin immer noch geschockt
war genial das muss man ihm lassen
er hat mir ganz schön gegeben ich kann's
nicht fassen
was eine schande
er hatte eigentlich einen guten ruf bis
das passiert ist jetzt denkt jeder im
ernst alter das musstest du machen um zu
gewinnen
du hast du nur deinen ruf dein wort und
deinen namen wenn eins davon beschädigt
wird ist es aus wenn du nicht da bist
der du vorgibt zu sein was vergessen die
nie
was geht in die geschichte ein ganz klar
aber sowas von
sie gehört zu den 70 prozent der
häftlinge die sich im gefängnis frei
bewegen dürfen er ist seit zehn jahren
in einem mosaik und lebt im größten
gebäude der haftanstalt
hier sind auf fünf stockwerken
380 insassen untergebracht
[Applaus]
immer zur vollen stunde können sie ihre
zelle verlassen oder in sie zurückkehren
dafür sorgt eine der wenigen wärterinnen
sie kontrolliert die insassen mit hilfe
eines einfachen aber effektiven systems
[Musik]
ich öffne jetzt die zellen
das bedeutet staat
innerhalb einer minute sind alle zellen
offen
das ist der mechanismus
wenn ich die hochtief geht die tür auf
wenn so was dran ist wollen sie nicht
dass ihre zelle geöffnet wird
sie sind vielleicht bei der arbeit und
wollen nicht dass jemand in ihre zelle
kann wenn sie nicht da sind das system
läuft über kabel und ist das gleiche sei
das gebäude 1932 gebaut wurde
sie sitzt in celle 37
er ist für sich allein einige
persönliche gegenstände sollen sein
leben hinter gittern erträglicher machen
[Musik]
das ist mein zugang zur außenwelt
so bekomme ich mit was gerade so los ist
im sport oder bei anderen sachen ich
kann serien schauen ist echt wichtig
meine hängt an der wand ist nicht bei
jedem so
und man braucht ein ventilator heute
haben wir 33 grad wenn ich den nicht
hätte wäre es die reinste quälerei er
ist absolut lebensnotwendig
fernseher und so alles egal
mit ventilator geht seinem gut
und ein tablet
darüber bekommt man seine e mails
so eins muss man haben
es sind filter drin weil man ins
internet kann
aber man hat zugang zu büchern und musik
und kann gedichte lesen oder so
das ist mein eigener raum
hilft mir nicht durchzudrehen der
einzige friedliche ort den es hier gibt
deswegen mache ich ihn mir so gemütlich
wie möglich
und das da
das ist meine traumfrau coco sie ist ein
model ich werde sie nie treffen aber ich
bin echt verknallt
ist mein mädchen ich liebe sie
man hat keinen sex aber es gibt
möglichkeiten
mit männern das würde ich nie machen
aber manche tun
ja
man muss eben machen was viele männer
tun
dafür sind die bilder
anders geht es nicht
zehn jahre man wenn man so lange keinen
sex hat muss man mental extrem stark
sein
das ist der preis den der anführer einer
gang dafür zahlt einen kunden ermordet
zu haben er wird den rest seines lebens
in der drei quadratmeter großen zelle
verbringen ohne kontakt zu seinen gang
kumpanen von denen viele bereits getötet
wurden
das sind meine freunde
die meisten sind schon tot manche sind
auf der straße gestorben wurden
erschossen
so läuft das eben
seit ich hier drin bin sind viele meiner
freunde gestorben ich hänge ihre bilder
auf um an sie zu erinnern
ich und die jungs die ihr hier seht
haben ein imperium aufgebaut
und das existiert da draußen noch
viele wurde als teenager mitglied der
platz er ist in der gang aufgestiegen
bis zum anführer der gruppe in ob wohl
er im gefängnis sitzt macht er immer
noch geschäfte er verdient geld für die
über 30 gang mitglieder die in einem
ausleben
ach so ich mache dies hier drinnen
gibt's leben wenn jemand hunger hat und
eine tüte chips will gebe ich ihm eine
und er gibt mir 2 zurück
kann ein paar wochen dauern aber ich
warte
so bekomme ich kohle und meine leute
können essen
denn die an was nicht rankommen schaffe
ich das sicher ich verkaufs und
verdienen was
so läuft das hier drin
können sie auch was rein schmuggeln
gibt's da wege
wissen sie
könnte sein
wenn ich wollte mehr will ich dazu nicht
sagen denn die gefängnisleitung
überwacht alles was in die haftanstalt
hineinkommt und was nach draußen geht
die werte haben einen guten instinkt
entwickelt verdächtiges verhalten zu
erkennen
vor über 20 jahren half dieser instinkt
jason hewitt dabei eine unglaubliche
entdeckung zu machen damals war er noch
recht neu im job
da stand mehr oder
im gefängnis ist er bekannt als der mann
der den ruf von ennemoser rettete am 14
juli 1998 durchsuchte er aufgrund des
verdächtigen verhaltens eines insassen
dessen zelle
die ecke wirkte irgendwie seltsam ein
spalt im boden nur wenige millimeter
breit erregte seine aufmerksamkeit als
er die abdeckung anhob traute hewitt
kaum seinen augen
darunter lag ein mehrere meter tiefer
tunnel
sie hatten die fliesen auf die abdeckung
geklebt
und darunter waren griffe damit sie sie
über sich ziehen konnten wenn sie unten
waren
das war unter dem bett
unter dem bett ging es rein wenn man
sich den rand des lochs ansieht erkennt
man spuren von dem großen meisel mit dem
sie gruben
ein äußerst seltener ausbruchsversuch
der tunnel befand sich in dem gebäude
mit niedrigster sicherheitsstufe dort
haben die häftlinge einen schlüssel
monate lang wechselten sich zehn oder
mehr insassen ab und gruben einen tunnel
durch den sie fliehen wollten das
werkzeug hatten sie in der gefängnis
werkstatt mitgehen lassen
sie hatten ein kabel im tunnel verlegt
für die beleuchtung mit
hilfe von ventilatoren sorgten sie für
luftaustausch und abkühlung
was ich dachte als ich das öffnete ganz
ehrlich das erste was mir durch den kopf
schoss war ach du scheiße war ein
seltsames gefühl
doch das war noch nicht alles als
officer hewitt in den tunnel stieg
entdeckte er dass dieser in einen
luftschacht mündete so was kennt man
sonst nur aus filmen die insassen
konnten sich nicht nur durchs gesamte
gebäude bewegen sie bekamen auch frische
luft
[Musik]
da oben sieht man himmel
wenn man da hochkletterte kamen aufs
dach
wenn sie genügend bettlaken gehabt
hätten hätten sie sie zusammenbinden und
an der fassade runter klettern können
officer hewitt hatte den spektakulärsten
ausbruchsversuch in der geschichte von
einem user vereitelt
[Musik]
diese typen denken 24 stunden am tag 7
tage die woche darüber nach was sie tun
kann und wir haben nur eine acht stunden
schicht und dahinter zu kommen
manche sind ziemlich genial
nach diesem vorfall ließ die
gefängnisleitung alle böden mit beton
versiegeln und die luftschächte
versperren
das macht einen ausbruch noch
unwahrscheinlicher
[Musik]
die beteiligten insassen wurden bestraft
und auf andere haftanstalten im land
verteilt
[Musik]
in den usa sind die werke immer in
alarmbereitschaft
ihnen entgeht nichts
und dazu gehört auch das abhören der
telefongespräche
20 minuten kosten zwei dollar und die
apparate sind jederzeit verfügbar
so hält auch silo kontakt zur außenwelt
im wachturm hört officer jones jeden
anruf mit
ein insasse der haftanstalt in einer
maus
um den anruf entgegenzunehmen
er nimmt die gespräche auf wird
überprüft worüber die häftlinge reden
gerade ist ein neuer anruf reingekommen
ich muss dann ihretwegen auf lautlos
stellen und die gespräche sind
vertraulich also nicht für die
öffentlichkeit
jones versucht mögliche vorhaben der
gangs aufzudecken er hört sich silos
gesamtes gespräch an
hier sitzen einige anführer von gangs
sie gegenüber telefon anweisungen zum
beispiel zeugen einzuschüchtern oder
jemanden mit dem sie ein problem haben
sie könnte noch organisieren dass bei
einem besuch drogen ins gefängnis
gebracht werden das abhören ist eine
wichtige überwachungsmethode durch die
wir so etwas aufdecken können
vor kurzem konnte er so wahrscheinlich
ein leben retten ein gangmitglied hatte
den telefonischen befehl erteilt seiner
untreue freundin ermorden zu lassen
süchtig er rief jemanden aus seiner
gängen seitdem er wolle dass man seine
freundin etwas antut
doch den mann mit dem sie zusammen ist
sein kumpel fragt ihn ob er sich ganz
sicher seine würde sich eine waffe
besorgen
dadurch dass ich mit gehört haben
konnten wir weitere gespräche
unterbinden
die anstifter kann man einzelhaft es
kann also tatsächlich leben retten
die häftlinge wissen dass sie abgehört
werden wenn silo mit seiner familie und
freunden telefoniert behält er das immer
im hinterkopf er hat seine eigene
methode das system zu unterwandern
ich sage nichts über die blatt weist
eine gang ist
wenn ich mit jemandem sprechen den ich
von der straße kennt kann der reden wie
er will
aber ich benutze code wörter
die könnte nämlich jederzeit ein recht
auf anrufe wegnehmen und dich in
einzelhaft stecken
30 prozent der insassen von einem außer
sind mitglied einer gang die
zugehörigkeit ist auch im gefängnis noch
sehr wichtig loyalität ist oberstes
gebot auch für diesen einbrecher ein
mitglied der krebs
die leute nennen es eine gang und sehen
nur das schlechte
es ist wie eine familie
ich würde für sie töten und sterben so
läuft das
ich bin über meine mom reingekommen und
es ist nicht leicht auszusteigen
wenn ich aussteigen könnte und das kann
ich würde ich trotzdem nicht machen ich
habe schon zu viel für sie getan und sie
für mich
[Musik]
wenn man im gefängnis mit seiner gang
bricht riskiert man sein leben in einem
user gibt es einen schutzbereich er
liegt im best gesicherten flügel
ja so berichtssaison bedeckt
um sie vor racheakten zu schützen wurden
diese häftlinge von den anderen getrennt
hier verbringen sie 24 stunden am tag
diese beiden insassen wurden von den pet
ausgeschlossen eine extrem gewalttätigen
gängen rechtsradikaler
puerto ricanerin geheiratet und
spanische kinder da war ich bei denen
unten durch
2010 hatte ich eine andere meinung als
der anführer
ein paar haben davon wind bekommen und
während ich am essen war haben die mich
zusammengeschlagen
seitdem darf ich mich bei denen nicht
blicken lassen
also bin ich hier gelandet
aber einmal ging immer gang das sind
tief obwohl es untersagt ist spielen sie
karten entgelt fürs glücksspiel gibt's
einzelhaft
kann auch spielen ohne zu wetten
aber das macht keinen spaß eine
zeitverschwendung ich will dabei auch
was verdienen
was passiert wenn sie nicht zahlen
wir kämpfen dem zeigen wir's und wenn es
nicht in der zelle will dann kämpfen wir
hier selbst wenn ich weggesperrt werden
mein kumpel treibt das geld schon ein
und der typ zahlt egal wie
als dieser häftling noch auf freiem fuß
war hat er mit ähnlich radikalen
methoden schulden eingetrieben deswegen
ist er hier
ich musste den typen abstechen weil er
mir meine kohle nicht geben wollte hab
fast lebenslang bekommen wurde aber
reduziert
ja bis oben hin voll mit crystal meth
hab dem typen in den hals und in die
stirn gestochen
aber warum ausgerechnet in die stirn was
klein den kopf weil ich dich erledigen
will du zahlst mich ich krieg dich
damit sie in einer moser nicht ihre
herkömmlichen methoden anwenden können
gibt es hier kein bargeld
jeder häftling hat eine karte die er in
der gefängnis- eigenen bank aufladen
kann
[Musik]
na ja alles klar ich bräuchte da fünf
drauf
der zahlungsverkehr läuft ausschließlich
elektronisch ab jeder der häftlinge hat
ein eigenes bankkonto darauf können ihre
familien einzahlen und falls sie
arbeiten wird ihr gehalt darauf
überwiesen
wenn sie geld auf ihre karte laden
wollen mache ich das
wenn geld reinkommt landet es auf ihrem
konto dann können sie davon etwas auf
ihre karte lagen
dadurch kann man alles besser regulieren
als wenn bargeld verwendet wird
an diesem fenster sieht officer wagners
täglich viele insassen
für spanien und nur red bull
denn in der bank ist zusätzlich ein
kleiner lebensmittelladen untergebracht
die häftlinge haben keinen zutritt doch
dank ihrer zahl karte können sie sich
ihr gefängnis leben etwas versüßen
es gibt eis für zwei dollar 50 chips
burger für einen dollar und frisches
obst
wenn sie in der kantine nichts gutes
gibt steht da draußen eine lange
schlange
officer war das weiß was sache ist wenn
ein häftling ein großeinkauf macht
versucht er wahrscheinlich selbst zu
verkaufen die insassen verwenden
lebensmittel auch um ihre spiele
schulden abzubezahlen
[Musik]
ich halte die augen offen
wenn jemand große mengen einkauf deutet
das darauf hin dass um geld gespielt
wird
das schulden
darauf achte ich
beobachte immer
wer arbeitet muss nicht tauschen und
verdient sein geld auf legale weise
in einer maus gibt es acht fabriken sie
bearbeiten aufträge von staatlichen
unternehmen
die insassen sind billige arbeitskräfte
67 prozent von ihnen gehen täglich zur
arbeit
[Musik]
so wie mario 6 uhr 45
sein tag beginnt mit stempeln
ich muss zur arbeit
ich drucke nummernschilder den ganzen
tag lang
[Musik]
mario und 20 seiner mithäftlinge stellen
alle nummernschilder des staates daher
eine million im jahr und das seit
doch nur insassen mit guter führung
dürfen in den fabriken arbeiten denn sie
hantieren mit potenziell gefährlichen
werkzeugen
[Musik]
das ist wahrscheinlich der einzige ort
an dem ich das in der tasche haben
es gibt vieles das ich schneiden muss
und das teppichmesser macht es mir
einfacher
ich habe mir seit etwa zehn jahren
nichts mehr zuschulden kommen lassen
es ist nicht schwer ehrlich zu bleiben
und bei der arbeit muss ich
mario wurde wegen raubüberfalls
verurteilt und arbeitet hier bereits
seit zehn jahren in dieser zeit hat er
sich hochgedient angefangen hat er als
reinigungskraft jetzt druckt er
nummernschilder
da können sie raus die anforderungen
sind genauso hoch wie in einer normalen
fabrik
ja
das ist mal sehen das hier ist ein
bisschen gelbstich
sie muss ich irgendwie wegkriegen
sie sind sehr genau
wenn ich das mache will ich es auch
richtig machen
entweder richtig oder überhaupt nicht
joah verdient ein facharbeiter 12 dollar
die stunde
trotz seiner erfahrung ist mario weit
davon entfernt
wie viel sie verdienen
etwa 140
1 40 pro stunde
unterbezahlt und überarbeitet ein dollar
40 pro stunde das sind 20 prozent von
ios mindestlohn für das unternehmen ein
lukratives geschäft trotzdem hat es
mario besser als manch anderer häftling
wenn ich meinen mit anderen jobs im
gefängnis vergleich wenig wesen nicht
mehr
das doppelte des durchschnitts meisten
kriegen 70 oder 75 sind mir ist was
doppelt so viel
worüber wir aber eigentlich reden
sollten
gesorgt dass mit den billigen
arbeitskräften nicht systeme
die länge der haftstrafe passt einfach
nicht
man sagt verbrechen und strafe
in anderen staaten bekommt man keine 25
jahre für raub
da kriegt man 6 bis 10
und hier so viel haben sie bekommen ja
25 jahre
25 jahre für den bewaffneten überfall
auf einen lebensmittelladen er habe
nicht geschossen und es gab keine
verletzten während er im gefängnis war
sind marios eltern gestorben jetzt hat
er niemanden mehr
hier zahle ich meine rechnung
bezahlt meine rechnung
einen keiner geld schickt muss man
irgendwie anders über leben und
ich in berlin ebenso
man muss sehen wo man bleibt
ich mache es auf dieser ich mache das
beste haus eine scheiß situation
mario hat eine acht stunden schicht
hinter sich stempel aus
wollt ihr sehen wie viel ich verdient
hat
[Musik]
da stehen die stunden 55 stunden und 37
minuten
76 dollar und 20 so viel habe ich im
moment an einem tag habe ich wohl zwei
minuten zu wenig gearbeitet wird auch
die minuten wert gelegt ja der dir mal
raus genommen
ich bin längst nicht der größte andere
für ihn genauso viel
bevor er geht muss mario das
teppichmesser zurückgeben
die arbeiter dürfen die fabrik erst
verlassen wenn sie all ihr werkzeug
ausgehändigt haben
'wir haben freunde der wärter in der
fabrik führt buch über die werkzeuge
alle könnten als waffen verwendet werden
was passieren könnte wer weiß sie
könnten sie mitnehmen versuchen
auszubrechen jemanden damit erstechen
alles mögliche
deswegen muss ich sicherstellen dass
alles weg geschlossen wird
würde mario sein teppichmesser nicht
zurückbringen bekäme er einzelhaft und
durfte wochenlang nicht arbeiten
[Musik]
in marius gebäude leben nur insassen mit
langen haftstrafen
er selbst wird erst in sieben jahren
entlassen doch es gibt etwas das ihm
hilft die verbleibende zeit besser zu
überstehen
das beste ist dass man blick auf die
straße hat seht ihr
da ist die straße es basiert zwar nicht
viel aber man kann menschen sehen die da
draußen leben nicht drin deswegen wollte
ich hier eine zelle
ein guter blick
auf der anderen seite sieht man nur das
innere des gefängnisses und dass sie
jeden tag
man kann beobachten wie die leute die
ihr leben leben und das ist etwas auf
das man sich freuen
andere schon mir hilft es zu wissen dass
das leben draußen normal weitergeht das
gefängnis ist nicht alles
man riecht die luft durch das fenster
kommt frische luft hier drin ist die
luft gefangen raster ist freie luft
hinter den gitterstäben
ein riesenunterschied
[Musik]
mario besucht niemand mehr
andere haben mehr glück und können ihre
familien sehen
der besuchsraum ist ihr tor zur
außenwelt
zweimal im monat verbringt ziel hier
drei stunden mit seiner ehefrau
[Musik]
mit dabei seine 21 jahre alte tochter
stella
[Musik]
im besuchsraum gibt es strikte
vorschriften
kilo darf seine frau nur wenige sekunden
lang umarmen sonst verliert er das
anrecht auf besuch
jeder körperkontakt findet unter dem
strengen blick des wärters statt häufig
versuchen besucher illegale stoffe
einzuschmuggeln
sexueller kontakt ist komplett untersagt
er hat ein haar gemacht
du siehst gut aus danke
versucht sie ist wie ein supermodel
ich muss auf dich aufpassen
habt ihr gesagt dass sie gut aussieht
sie ist anders aus ich muss sich auch
mal verändern
ich mag dreadlocks macht ihn jünger
als ihr vater ins gefängnis kam war es
ja erst elf jahre alt
ich dachte nur er hat ärger kommt bald
zurück
nichts ernstes aber
was ernstes sie haben bislang vor mir
geheim gehalten wir standen uns sehr
nahe
wir waren jeden tag zusammen ist echt
seltsam
anhören sie es begriffen
ich glaube an meinem 3 zehnten
geburtstag
er hat immer gesagt er würde nach hause
kommen
aber dann hat er wieder einen geburtstag
verpasst
waren sie wütend auf ihn
nein das könnte ich gar nicht
dafür stehen wir uns zu nah
ich war traurig aber
nie wütend
ich bin stolz auf dich
auch wenn ich hier drin bin muss ich
kontakt mit ihr erhalten
schwer mit der distanz aber telefonate
und besuche helfen
für sienna und ihre mutter war das
urteil lebenslang ein schock
[Musik]
doch
ich mag gar nicht darüber nachdenken ein
leben bis dein leben
solange er lebt und atmet werde ich ihn
besucht
es ist gnade und fluch zugleich
das ist es
ja
das ist ihr familienleben
momente im besuchsraum
pass auf dich auf war schön dich zu
sehen
[Musik]
hast du heute versucht mich zu schlagen
ja
sagst das besser niemanden drin wirst du
mich nie schlagen vergiss es
hab dich lieb
dich mach ich
[Musik]
wenn ich hierher zurückkommen hat die
realität nicht wieder
ich komme aus den besuchsraum setze mich
hin und alles ist wie immer
die fotos helfen mir weiter zu machen
jeden tag denke ich an sie bei allem was
ich mache denke ich was es für sie
bedeuten würde
wenn sie mich nicht sehen durfte weil
ich einen fehler gemacht hat
wenn ich was dummes macht könnte ich
unsere beziehung gefährden
meine tochter hilft mir auf dem boden zu
bleiben
[Musik]
selbst für den stärksten mann in einer
moschee ist es schwierig der
deprimierenden realität zu entfliehen so
geht es auch den über 50.000 anderen
häftlingen in den usa ihr restliches
leben hinter gittern verbringen
für mario sieht es etwas besser aus
wegen raubüberfalls wurde er zwar zu
einer haftstrafe von 25 jahren
verurteilt aber dank guter führung
könnte er bereits 2025 entlassen werden
dann wäre er 54 jahre alt
wir machen einfach weiter
mario wird ennemoser wahrscheinlich
lebendig verlassen doch viele werden
hier ihren letzten atemzug tun
die verstorbenen die keine familie mehr
haben werden auf dem gelände der
haftanstalt beigesetzt auf dem gefängnis
eigenen friedhof
diese ohne enthält die asche eines
häftlings der mit 65 jahren gestorben
ist er war wegen sexuellen missbrauchs
verurteilt worden
jeder insasse hat das recht auf die
gleiche beerdigung an der nehmen die
gefängnisleitung und einige wörter teil
sie geben ihm das letzte geleit
[Musik]
danke dass sie heute gekommen sind
wie immer kümmert sich rick ein
ehemaliger wörter um die letzte
ruhestätte des häftlings
jeder sollte eine ordentliche beerdigung
gekommen auch wenn er ein insasse war
war er ein mensch
mittlerweile sind 152 häftlinge über den
tod hinaus geblieben im
hochsicherheitsgefängnis einem aus